Laurance Magick Dennis
Part of the appeal for us for moving here, originally, was so that our children
could be raised in an environment where they know what love is
Laurance Magick Dennis
where they know what care is; where they know their responsibilities of
caring for country as Aboriginal people.
Laurance Magick Dennis
Out here in the rural area where we’re living, it’s possible for us
to teach our kids those values, without the outside influences of our people
Laurance Magick Dennis
living in poverty due to systemic racism; our people living in harsh conditions
with drugs and alcohol around them; the over-policing of our people.
Laurance Magick Dennis
So our kids weren’t subjected to those outside influences
and so that they can be raised in a way that was strong culturally, spiritually and ethically.
Laurance Magick Dennis
They’re aware of all that stuff that’s happening with our people
but so that they’re not subjected to it, so that they can be strong for when
Laurance Magick Dennis
it does come and meet them face to face.
So that they can stand and face it like we’ve had to.